[Music]
[Applause]
mangoes are picked
in one of three ways the first is with a
harvest aid
this is where a team of people pick
mangoes and place or gently throw them
onto a tarp pollen
either with the stems on or off there
are different types of these machines
and you may either pick from the ground
or from a platform fruit are either snap
picked or picked with secateurs or
picking sticks
when snap picking the fruit is grasped
at the bottom and then the bottom of the
fruit is lifted up
snapping the stem of the fruit before it
is put onto the harvest aid
sat may spurt from the mango when it is
picked this way and it is important that
the sap doesn't contact the mango skin
your skin or the skin of other pickers
to neutralize the sap
a chemical commonly called mango wash is
sprayed onto the tarpaulin
and over the conveyor that collects the
fruit if the stems are removed
it is important that the fruit is placed
onto the tarpaulin within five seconds
otherwise the sap will burn the skin if
the stem is still on the fruit
the fruit must be distemmed either under
a spray or in a bath of mango wash
the fruit must be left under the spray
or in the bath for one minute
to protect the fruit from sap if you get
sap on your hands
it is important that you wash this sap
from your hands before you touch any
other mango fruit
as even a smaller amount of sap can
damage the fruit a picking stick is used
to pick mangoes you can't reach from the
ground
it has a set of cutting blades to cut
the stem and a set of jaws to hold the
stem when it is cut
the jaws of the picking stick must be
facing down so the fruit isn't dropped
after it is picked
once on the harvest aid the fruit flows
from the spray
or bath along a conveyor and drops into
a bulk bin
for transport to the packing shed it is
good practice for the fruit to fall onto
a foam pad
when it falls into the bulk bin and this
pad must be repositioned
as the fruit fills the bin
[Music]
the second way mangoes are picked is
with a hydraulic ladder called a cherry
picker a cherry picket is operated by a
single person
and moves up and down and inside and
around the tree
the fruit is snapped from the tree and
placed into a picking bag
mango wash is sprayed over the fruit to
neutralize the sap
when the picking bag is full it is
lowered to the ground
and emptied gently into a bulk bin for
transport to the packing shed
it is important that all fruit in the
bag is covered by mango wash
so do not over fill the bag before
emptying
third way to pick mangoes is to pick
with the stems intact
and the fruit is de-sapped in the
packing shed using secateurs or picking
sticks
fruit is picked with a 10 to 20
centimetre stem attached
and placed into crates and transported
to the packing shed care must be taken
when placing the fruit in the crate
and during handling and transport so the
mango stems
aren't broken and mango sap does not
come into contact with the skin
these crates are stacked for transport
or short-term storage in the packing
shed
so it is important that they are not
overfilled and fruit damaged or stems
broken
when they are stacked if the mangoes
have been picked with the stems on
these stems need to be removed and the
mangoes decept before packing
this can be done either through snapping
the stems or using machine
which cuts the stem from the fruit
during this process it is important that
the mango fruit are completely covered
in a detergent solution
before the stem is removed so the sap
does not come into contact with the skin
and damage it
as well as damage from sap burn mango
quality can be lost through physical
injury from incorrect picking technique
and rough handling
damage from sap burn or physical injury
takes one to two days to appear
and isn't usually seen until fruit
reaches market take four to six weeks
for them to come back and repurchase
that product
it's therefore important that both the
visual and eating qualities of a mango
match consumer expectations
so why is this important for mango
pickers
even the simple task of picking a mango
fruit can have a significant impact
on the visual and eating qualities of a
fruit and therefore the profitability of
the grower
the aim of this video is to teach you
how to pick mango fruit correctly
and learn the skills required you'll
learn how to select fruit that is mature
and ready to harvest you'll learn how to
use the different equipment you'll be
using during the picking process
you'll understand how poor pecking
processes can significantly damage mango
fruit
and you'll understand how to pick
without injuring yourself or other
pickers
there are names for the different parts
of the mango the stem
end is the top of the mango that's where
it's attached to the tree
the cheek is the side of the mango
that's the part you eat
the blush is the red pink or orange
color on the cheek
the nose is the bottom part of the mango
you may hear terms like
soft nose used when fruit has a defect
and the beak
is the pointed part near the nose
[Music]
mangoes are picked in a hard green
mature state so they'll ripen
to an acceptable eating quality and
external appearance
at this stage the fruit is hard and the
skin is green
apart from the blush the shape of a
mango fruit changes as the fruit matures
the mature fruit on the left is more
rounded and oval-shaped as opposed to
the egg-shaped immature fruit on the
right
as the fruit matures the nose end of the
fruit fills out and is smoother and the
beak is less obvious
from left to right on this slide the
fruit goes from immature to mature
the beak of the fruit is much more
prominent in the immature fruit
on the left than the mature fruit on the
right when these fruit are ripened
the immature fruit stays green while the
more mature fruit will change color to
yellow
the shoulder of the fruit also fills out
around the stem and the stem sits in a
small depression
when the fruit matures it is important
to only pick mature fruit as fruit
maturity can have a significant impact
on eating quality of mangoes
you need to be particularly careful with
the first sap that comes from the
mangoes when you pick it
this is called spurt sap if spurt sap
comes in contact with the skin of the
mango it can
damage the skin this is called sap burn
this set can also burn
your skin or skin of other pickers sap
can continue to ooze from the fruit for
several hours
and although this sap isn't as damaging
as spurt sap it can still cause skin
browning and reduce the sale price of
mangoes
the types of physical injury include
abrasion cuts and scratches
stem punctures crease marks wounds and
internal bruising
abrasion shows as brown marks on the
skin often with scratches through the
mark
it is caused by the skin of the fruit
rubbing against dirty dusty equipment or
crates
and bulk bins or sticks and leaves in
the crates and bins
cuts and scratches occur when the sharp
edge of a picking stick
or secateurs not the fruit or when the
fruit scrapes against a twig or a branch
as is pulled from the tree
stem punctures occur when the stem is
not completely removed
and the short stem punctures another
fruit as it is placed onto the harvest
aid
as it rolls into the bulk bin or through
pressure from other fruit
in the bulk bin crease marks occur when
the fruit impacts heavily against the
edge of equipment
crates or bins when the blunt parts of a
picking stick knock the fruit
wounds occur when the fruit contacts a
sharp edge and the skin of the fruit is
pierced
monitoring of picking crews has shown
the effect poor picking practices and
rough handling has on physical damage on
fruit
at one orchard fruit was assessed for
physical damage on arrival at the
packing shed
damage to the fruit from different
picking teams ranged from 2
to 17 so for the worst team
17 of the fruit had already been
downgraded when it reached the shed
resulting in significant losses to the
grower
[Music]
[Applause]
mangoes are picked during the hottest
part of the year
the work is hard and constant and
temperatures in the orchard
often reach above 35 degrees celsius
there is little shade in the orchard so
it is very important that you follow a
few precautions when you are picking
wear the right clothes to protect you
from the sun lightweight long-sleeve
shirts and long trousers are recommended
wear a rod brimmed hat and good shoes
eye protection in the form of sunglasses
is also recommended
apply sunscreen before you start picking
each day and at least every two hours
during the day
drink water regularly during the day and
at least four liters each day
when you are snapping the fruit from the
tree make sure the sap doesn't spurt
onto you or other pickers
some people are highly sensitive to
mango sap and can develop a severe rash
from contact with the sap
if you're spurted with mango sap it is
important that you wash the area with
soap and water and then rinse it well
with fresh water
as a picker it is important that you
understand how manga quality can be lost
and why it is important you follow the
simple steps outlined in this video
to reduce quality loss some do's and
don'ts when picking mangoes
the do's do understand fruit maturity
and only pick mature fruit
be gentle with a fruit make sure mangoes
are in the mango wash within five
seconds of being picked
wash the mango sap from your hands or
skin wear the right clothes and drink
lots of water when you're picking
mangoes
and be careful around heavy equipment
the don'ts
don't make immature fruit don't hit
fruit with picking equipment
don't handle fruit roughly or throw it
against the hard edges of harvest aids
bins or crates don't let mango sap come
into contact with mango's skin
and don't let mango sap come into
contact with your skin your eyes or the
skin of other pickers
as you can see picking mangoes is more
difficult than it seems
and now you can understand why you have
been instructed to pick the fruit
the way you have everybody has a role in
optimising mango fruit quality
you